there are only about 150 speakers of the
ocracoke brogue now
and they all live on one end of this
barrier island on the coast of north
carolina which is basically an enlarged
sand bar within
the next 50 years the brogue will
disappear hoy choice is last night water
for night moonshine no feast
the dialect on this island is sometimes
referred to as hoy toiters which is
their pronunciation of high tide toyed
on the south side high tide on the south
side in the united states the ocracoke
brogue is probably the only dialect that
is not identified
as being from america i do have a lot of
people that think i'm from australia or
or uh ireland yeah you look at these
boats he sees crabs you know the first
people came here from england and
ireland scotland just aid isolating i'm
from ocracoke
i am the 10th generation
in my family from ocracoke that goes
back to the
mid 1600s
the reason this dialect was perpetuated
for a couple of centuries was because
the people were very isolated they
didn't have much contact with with
people from the mainland
ocracoke is an island that has always
lived around the water got it
many of the unique items particularly
the vocabulary items
are built around the water
and the sand and the weather the wind
blowing really hard he said blowing it's
blowing hard in a popcorn right there
you know
you taking a ride around the island you
just take a little scoot
when we come out here and the wind is
blowing really hard
and we take a big i take a bad beating
then you could say we'd be a mama
you also find here lots of terms for
outsiders y'all are dingbatters
just
my wife is a maryland we've been married
43 years she's still a dingbatter
that's not a bad thing okay
it was basically the dingbatters who
changed the dialect because so many
people came in even today there are more
off islanders who live here than
onliners
now it's changing within time we're all
going to lose it you know
because of
so many people came in it's a part of a
heritage that i'm proud of
some people think we talk funny i think
that's the way we talk
it ain't funny to us but it doesn't
matter i mean that's fine you know